are you out of touch with your  generation no look I it's true that I  was into Bernie before it was cool and  the qualities I admired then our  qualities I still respect a great deal I  never said that I agree with every part  of his policy views then or now but I  appreciate that it at least he's  straightforward and honest about him  he's honest about the fact that taxes  will go up on anybody making more than  twenty nine thousand dollars to fund his  health care plan although again  a little bit vague about how the rest  about being out as the premiums should  be eliminated but you're still raising  those taxes in a way people money  because they don't pay any premiums  out-of-pocket expenses co-payments or  deductibles they can be much better off  but where's the other where's the other  twenty five trillion dollars supposed to  come from there's one point you gotta do  the math about we got it all  you